welcome back to the machine learning
Street Talk YouTube channel today we
spoke with Robert lanch Robert is an
incredible guy I would classify him as a
kind of classical polymath he is one of
these guys that just has an incredible
broad and diverse set of interests and I
get the feeling that we could have spoke
to him about absolutely anything and he
would have loved to you know have
continued the conversation so we
introduced Robert on the show properly
so I won't spend too much time now but
just to signpost the structure of the
show for about 20 minutes or so we spoke
about economics and Roberts journey into
machine learning we spoke about
multi-agent reinforcement learning and
weather systems like this could help us
improve society we spent about 20
minutes or so talking about intelligence
and system 1 and system 2 and about
Sciales conception of intelligence and
whether modern reinforcement learning
systems are intelligent and so on and
then in the final hour we spoke all
about Roberts recent article on pruning
methods now robert's article is
absolutely amazing he's got a real gift
when it comes to presenting and
distilling information and he starts the
journey all the way from Franco's
original lottery ticket hypothesis last
year and then almost on a kind of ticket
my ticket basis if you'll pardon the pun
he goes through and talks about all of
the advances in the field you know
things like rewinding the early stages
of neural network training the linear
mode connectivity talking about whether
these tickets and architectures
generalized to other data and other
domains and so on it was a wonderful
conversation and this was definitely one
of my favorite episodes so I really hope
you enjoy at the session today remember
to Like comment and subscribe and we'll
see you back next week peace out
[Music]
I have two cameras on teams I'm not
going to bother doing a separate channel
so I can dynamically switch between
coffee on standby over here that's a
really good camera yeah it's beautiful
it's got that 80 mm lens on it
85 mil lens so anything in the
background is blurry your shoulders look
like wide like you buff oh really yeah
[Laughter]
would you have 30,000 subscribers now
had it not been for Corona well maybe
not it's true well the first week I took
a break on the weekend I was like I'm
gonna upload every weekday and then I
just forgot it was weekend the week
after and then yeah I didn't stop yeah I
was trying to make a video this morning
about partial dependency plots and I did
it in your style you know drawing on the
OneNote and I just don't know how you do
it honestly I I just it up again
and again and again and then I just
stopped recording
and could you know you do this thing
where you're like well basically the
expectation means this and and this is
what integration is and this is what
blah blah you know this is what a
marginalization is now it's kind of
drawing it and just yeah just you know
just not fluidly articulating it so I
just kind of thought that's I can't
you know that's not gonna work well I
find it really depends I made a video
about them so I I'm making videos right
now about kind of old papers okay
and I I made one about work Tyvek and
that's oh yes that's wrappi paper so I
was I was crap as well and I made
another one about residual networks and
that's a really good paper so that comes
really so I find it has a lot to do with
what Europe's like if the source
material is really good it's super easy
but then the word to back papers just
the one it's like blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah so we did and I think the
video is equally bad about it yeah but
which paper did you do because you know
they were too little middle one the one
where they introduced the negative
sampling and this serious 3/4 exponent
and yeah I did a video on that okay
wonderful so welcome back to the machine
learning Street Talk YouTube channel and
podcast today we have Robert land
Robert is really well known in the
community he's got one of the most
beautiful blogs that I've ever seen in
my entire life so much so I'm going to
share my screen and show you
robert's blog okay so this is Roberts
web page here and on the about Me
section Roberts got loads of stuff
captured let's start off on on Robert
see because I honestly think this is a
beautiful TV from an education point of
view he started off doing a BSC at the
University of Cologne I went to Cologne
once I met some crazy Germans in Ibiza
and we had a New Year's party in Cologne
and I don't remember much about it
because it was a bit of a blur
but anyway he did his his first master's
in data science at the Barcelona School
of Economics and he ranked second out of
25 he then went on to do an MSC in
machine learning with a distinction at
Imperial College London which is one of
the elite universities in the UK and
he's currently studying a PhD in
multi-agent reinforcement learning at
the Technical University in Berlin and
from a work perspective there's some
stuff here as well
he's a cognitive computational
neuroscientist on a PhD lab rotation at
the Einstein Center for neurosciences in
Berlin he's also been a data scientist
intern at Accenture and he's got an
incredible blog I mean just look at the
way this is presented it's it's really
colorful and if we look on Roberts blog
he's just done this really interesting
article all about the lottery ticket
hypothesis which we're going to get into
today but he's also done stuff on for
example the measure of intelligence
Yannick has given me strict instructions
to only mentions chale about three or
four times because apparently I and
every other word I reference surely but
there's some really good stuff here
about reinforcement learning for example
cue learning and if you look at the
style of Roberts articles they're really
colorful they've got loads of images on
there and I think Roberts got a real
gift when it comes to distilling down
information
and making it really easy to understand
so that's fantastic now the other thing
is there's a section on here about some
kind of personal information from Robert
kind of justifying why he wanted to you
know the journey that he's taken and how
he's ended that where he is now and he
said that his decision to study
economics was driven by the desire to
understand and ultimately solve social
inequality and poverty and he said that
his projects mainly focused on public
policy evaluation and the intersection
of retirement and unemployment insurance
systems for example and at some point he
discovered the beauty of machine
learning and reinforcement learning and
he's Eddie Aldo Faisal helped him to
explore and exploit the unknown unknowns
and he's also really interested in
intelligence so he said that his work at
the intersection of computational
linguistics and the hierarchical
reinforcement learning made Robert
realized the need for a deeper
understanding of the mechanisms at the
bottom of this page he talks a little
bit about reinforcement learning so
Robert says that his current research
focus lies at the intersection of
reinforcement learning and complex swarm
dynamics so Roberts very interested in
collective behavior and intrinsic
motivation and so on and Robert said he
wants to solve the intertemporal as well
as the interagency silent problem and
there's also a wonderful image here that
Robert calls shepherding an agent base
and nudging and and I know that Roberts
has huge ambitions here for this to be
something which can be beneficial for
our society so there's loads of anchor
points there for interesting things we
can talk about Robert welcome to the
show thank you Tim now is probably the
most extensive and and colorful
introduction I ever got in my life
thanks for that having on the show I
gotta say I'm a huge fan of all of your
work and I've been following many of the
the papers being reviewed by Yannick and
a lot of the Saturday morning reads by
Connor and I've also listened to some of
your podcasts so thank you for having me
thank you thank you thank you so much
for coming so why don't you just give us
a little bit of a story about your
journey into machine learning your
passions I know you're fascinated by you
know multi-agent reinforcement learning
and intelligence I do
love to hear it articulated from from
you sure so and it obviously comes with
a danger of a lot of kind of ex post
explaining of decisions and I guess when
I'm riding on my about me pages is
already part of that so I started off
doing economics meaning out of I know I
guess naive altruistic reasons and
during that time I can't realize that
economics is really good at describing
social phenomena and in problems but not
necessarily a very good at tackling them
and in the sense that I kind of
envisioned when I started it but during
the same time I realized that I really
love statistics and game theory and that
kind of led to me transitioning into
into statistics and data science and
then I went to Barcelona and from
Barcelona to to London since I didn't
get enough and in math Ilona
I met see my previous supervisor and he
works basically at the intersection of
neuroscience and and that's how I
ultimately ended up in in Berlin and
working on computational cognitive
neuroscience projects and now working
also on math agent reinforcement
learning within in this excellence class
through called signs of intelligence
which is a very new project with in
Berlin trying to combine different
disciplines in the study of intelligence
so it's very much kind of up to my alley
in terms of having a very broad
perspective on intelligence and I'm
combining psychology cognitive science
ethology machine learning computer
science physics and that's what I'm
doing right now and during my weekends
I'm also writing blog posts and taking a
lot of notes you have a beautiful style
of presenting and distilling information
there's a degree of being an artist in
there I would say we were talking with
Zach Jobs last weekend and he said that
teaching is part of the process of
learning there's a distillation there
what does that process look like for you
yeah so what I really early realized is
that I personally only look at notes
when they are pretty and they are having
a certain level of compression
and it makes it easier for me to to get
back into it pretty quickly and that's
something I try to to learn but also a
kind of to to maximize and out of this
kind of desire to compress and to
consolidate these visual notes kind of
kind of arised
and yeah I gotta say this project is
very much inspired by a PhD student
called Natalia Velez from Stanford and I
met her at a neuroscience conference and
she she does basically exactly and not
exactly the same but something similar
in the nearest science world and she
does a way better job in terms of
painting the and visualizing the the
actual speakers I never do that but yeah
I I really enjoyed doing something like
that and also giving back to the
community by by having these visual
notes contact so I'm kind of interested
in your in your kind of economics
background so you started off in
economics and you you wanted to or
according to Tim you wanted to solve you
know issues related to poverty and so on
do you think the multi-agent
reinforcement learning that you're doing
now can be applied back or are you still
are you still kind of with one eye
looking into the direction of of solving
these problems I heard the term nudging
which I guess economists economists have
this there's one philosophy where you
say we'll just do broad interventions
and then there's this other philosophy
where you say what's kind of the minimum
intervention we need to do to get people
to do you know what we want them to do
ultimately is there is there like a
connection you you do anything with
multi-agent reinforcement learning in
that direction so that's a really good
question and it's me I feel like I also
kind of I started with economics I kind
of fell out of love a little bit but now
I'm sort of back into looking at
collective behavior and to be entirely
honest the the techniques are also
fairly similar like the the whole
concept of Markov decision processes
also exists within the world of
computational economics it's not like
yeah machine learning or people studying
animal conditioning kind
I entered this my lawyer yeah it's all
over the field and I don't know if you
saw this but recently Salesforce has had
this paper called the AAI economist
right yeah they also j2i deep
reinforcement learning concepts to to
optimal taxation
so yeah annexation is all about
incentives right how do you want to set
a tax rate so that people are
incentivized to to work but at the same
time kind of maximizing a form of public
good and providing to the greater
society right so you're completely right
they're all these kind of connections
and I feel like more and more people are
kind of exploring this so at the moment
I'm attending virtual mlss summer school
and on Friday Costas desk I lacus they
have a really nice talk on the
intersection of game theory machine
learning and mechanism design which is
essentially a field of economics which
studies the optimal design of certain
structures in an economy here so that
people maximize well-being implicitly
basically on the subject of their
salesforce paper Yannick did a video
about that quite recently and one of the
take-home messages from the paper was
that you should tax the poor people more
and it's really fascinating because well
a lot of people denigrated the paper
saying oh we can't possibly take this
seriously and in industry as well I've
heard people say well we should be
trying to create realistic simulations
even if they are reductions of reality
to help us learn something about public
policy or about strategy so is it
something that we can meaningfully learn
from or is it just a trivial thing well
I may be I to expand a little bit on on
this question it's very good I've had a
lot of criticism you have people not to
me but towards the paper saying
basically saying you know this this
simulation is so wrong every everything
that comes out of it is just an artifact
of the simulation for example it
wouldn't tax the rich people except the
very super-rich you attack them tax them
super duper much because they can just
can't move to another country right
they're stuck there and and that would
like completely change once you are
after like a free market of countries
where the rich people can move once
their tax so I guess yeah what what Tim
Tim is do you think that even though we
don't have good approximations or good
enough approximations to the real world
like there's always gonna be something
missing can we still learn things from
reinforcement learning like simulations
according to how safe salesforce does it
or is that like the complete wrong way
could I add a facet in as well it seemed
to demonstrate that there is a
specialization of roles and it seemed to
demonstrate that once people had been
cast into a particular role it was
impossible for them to change their
position in society that that appears to
be a natural phenomenon and maybe it
could help us design strategies to
increase social mobility so I gotta be
honest I don't know enough about the
economists paper but something that
economics has been doing for basically
since the dawn of existence is make
assumptions about behavior and about
preferences and utility functions and I
think formalizing this as a
reinforcement learning problem is
inherently nothing bad right in some
sense it it gives a different pair or a
different perspective on the problem and
yeah I think it's it's nothing nothing
nothing bad but the same kind of
question also arises in the simulation
of motor control for example and ajikko
simulations where you can only simulate
so much of physics basically right
without kind of making the simulation
too slow to actually generate
transitions from which you can learn and
so I guess how much you have stacked
away from simulation is it's critical in
what you can learn from or from it right
and these choices really have to make
have to be be made made explicitly and
yeah so that's basically my take but I'm
a prior just just on that point about it
being nothing bad I think it's hard to
argue that these things are morally
neutral it's a similar thing with the
laocoon debate about that racial bias
the other day there you know some people
might say that
as soon as you have this
anthropomorphize ation of machine
learning models then all of a sudden
there's a whole load of stuff that comes
with it and with this Salesforce paper
it was basically saying that you should
tax the poor people more tax the rich
people less there is a difference on the
on the spectrum of political opinion
people on the right thing for rich
people create wealth and they should be
taxed more and that's a good thing
whereas people on the Left think we
should redistribute the wealth in
society so when something like this
comes along and seems to agree with the
conservative school of thought that that
could arguably be a moral ill okay okay
then let me take this back I thought
your question was if I think it's
something but good to phrase it as a
reinforcement learning problem with an
environment which you can simulate and I
think that's a unique perspective right
I didn't think that the conclusion is
something that I Doris right that's
that's not what I'm saying yes
absolutely yeah so yeah but I also hope
that the decision makers who have to
ultimately implement this have a forum
of yeah conscious and and think about
their state of knowledge when it comes
to reinforcement learning algorithms and
yeah the state of deep learning itself
right so they're thinking about these
simulations is incredibly interesting
like I remember in undergrad classes
where you'd have the simulation of the
foxes and the rabbits and they just have
this deterministic behavior to reproduce
or eat the rabbits and now we have
simulations where the agents are like
thinking of this reinforced learning
framework they have neural networks I
think it's definitely a really powerful
framework that'll lead to some really
interesting research yeah and especially
when you think of modern game simulators
like unity like the the possibilities
are growing immensely around and there
was this really cool work by by deep
mind where they assimilate a virtual
rodent right we had a bunch of
proprioception and yeah I believe really
trying to tackle these big questions
whether or not being economics and
things like the well-being of the
society or our motor control really can
benefit from from better and more
enhanced and more explicit simulations
can you give me an example of a
multi-agent reinforcement learning
problem like some kind of benchmark or
that really motivates your interest in
it so I personally am working basically
at the intersection of Mattie agent
reinforcement learning and ethology and
here in Berlin I briefly spoke about the
science of intelligence last year we
have a collaboration between people who
who study fish in real fish tanks and
people like me who work more on the on
the computational level and for example
right now what we're trying to do is try
to learn from from the real fish in the
fish tanks how they perform exploration
and to see whether or not we can
replicate or identify mechanisms that we
can then distill into a multi agent
green forcement learning systems and the
way how this works is we have fish tanks
and we have a 4k camera on top of them
and we have a tracking system and we can
a by.ya computationally or quantity
quantity how they how they behave and
yeah that's basically is something that
I'm currently looking into I'm a mess on
the on the let's let's improve
performance by a 2% on a specific
starcraft map as on the side of kind of
trying to distill mechanisms of
intelligent exploration into the fish
and the fish use go Explorer how our
computationally demanding is the
starcraft experiments well it's nothing
that you prototype within a day for
example right and for a young PhD
student yeah who still has to learn it
quite a lot it's it's not really at the
platform or in the game on which you
kind of build up intuition about
hyperparameters in multi-agent
reinforcement learning that's for sure
but there are many other kind of
settings or environments for multi-agent
reinforcement learning like simple
predator prey environments and for
example another game that has been
popular is is Jahnavi environment right
so an obvious another multi-agent and
cat game where theory of mind is
basically something that is very
essential for for collaborating agents
and there are different versions which
downscale Izanami game to make it run
faster and to actually yeah build up
fast
experimental work for us on this
societal thing I think I did a video
about Natasha Jax's ICML paper about the
enhancing motivation there is a while
ago now but some of the themes that came
out of that for me was about you know
there are some societal dilemmas like
the tragedy of the Commons or the
prisoner's dilemma and so on and to what
extent do you think we should be relying
on autonomous agents to be behaving in
society or do you think we need some
kind of centralization so it's a one
framework in multi-agent reinforcement
learning that has been proposed I think
by the group of Shimon Watson is this
concept of centralized training and
decentralized control so that means that
during training time agents have access
to to information from the other agents
so we have for example that could be
gradients or observations and and then
during test time muscle during
deployment time essentially this this is
not no longer the case so one example is
yeah sharing a critic so in actor critic
methods one can or one usually uses the
critic to essentially give the actor a
form of signal that tells the the actor
to upwe the probability to reinforce the
probability of a certain action in a
specific state and this can can use
centralized information in training but
during testing you don't need this this
critic anymore and I think if we
actually want to deploy something in the
real world
having decentralized control is really
really critical because managing all the
information in a centralized way it can
be quite computationally demanding and
since everything has to be real-time as
well it kind of becomes yeah very hard
so taking that thought a little bit
further in the real world if we could
learn something from these
reinforcements multi-agent reinforcement
learning systems could that translate to
the kind of change that you would like
to implement in society in the absence
of some kind of centralization I'm just
interested if you turn this into policy
okay so do you think that would work
you're starting to ask the utility
Streetman questions here I gotta be
honest one of my favorite episodes on
the next Freedman podcast was with
Michael Jordan right and he tended to
kind of yeah say that it doesn't know
the answer and that you will regret
saying anything about it so I guess I'm
pulling that video right now is there is
there some is there something like not
must not be in regards to this
particular thing but is that something
that you have learned through your you
know study of combat combining economics
intelligence whatnot with with
reinforcement learning that like an
unpopular opinion but that you are quite
convinced that if we implement it would
lead to some better better outcome in
society so I think I wouldn't be doing
what I'm doing if I don't didn't believe
that that bringing is fundamental right
and yeah many okay it's pretty
differently what I definitely learned
from my economics undergrad is that
economics is very very hard and it's
oftentimes underestimated when when
people talk about the financial crisis
and how bad all the economists did and
how unable they are and yeah I would
hope I would hope that machine learning
is going to be able to enhance our
decision-making and there are many other
kind of domains where people try to for
example get better inflation estimates
by using real time prices that are being
used to trade online on Amazon or on the
App Store and so on and I think all
these these problems and in economics
can definitely benefit from from a more
data driven more learning driven
perspective that machine learning
provides contrast what the modus
operandi is in economics I mean what are
the challenges because you come into a
very quantitative
slightly different discipline I would
say so how is it different and what what
are the big challenges that you think
those folks in the economics world are
wrestling with so I guess one problem
that or one field in economics that
really fascinates me is mr. field of
behavior
economics right and that's also that the
field that kind of makes or it has the
most overlap with what I'm doing right
now I would say and in behavioral
economics many of the fundamental
questions of the axioms of choice for
example or more broader assumptions in
economics are being questioned and
people try to empirically investigate
whether or not humans really make
decisions based on on some form of
rationality and there's this whole work
from Daniel Kahneman and I think these
experiments are really fundamental in
understanding human decision-making but
also in understanding how reinforcement
learning agents should act and yeah I
believe we need a lot more of that but
again I have been out of the the field
quite a bit now or in like at least four
years and I've never really dug interior
into like the really big questions deep
enough to really say that I'm qualified
to answer this question
so maybe with respect to something like
intrinsic motivation which appears to
it's it's kind of a thing that pulls
through everything right through
psychology and now even with the fish
you kind of have like how do the fish
explore and I've seen intrinsic
motivation discussed since then since
papers in the 90s or even before right
is there's there's I don't know in the
90s they just wrote down their ideas
about intrinsic motivation and there are
so many and there seem to be new ones
coming out every day which tells me
something like it doesn't work yet do
you what do you think is like the
biggest roadblock or what do you think
is the biggest the best approach to
intrinsic motivation from you know from
everything you've seen that that gives
us the biggest promise of coming as
close as possible to something like real
like a like a human would would do
something so let me start start off
differently so there's a lot of work I
kind of also starting with you mokuba
right on kind of surprised based
intrinsic motivation and curiosity and
there's been a lot of kind of progress
being done in
by putting this into the realm of
unsupervised or self-professed learning
using using more deep learning
approaches and most of them suffer from
from this kind of television problem
where you put an agent in front of a
television where there is some white
noise being displayed right and this
white noise looks different at every
time step right so it's gonna like lead
to surprise at every time step and these
kind of intrinsic motivation
formulations would then give the age and
a positive freeboard for beams new state
even though nothing has changed about
the world and only the pixels of the
white noise have changed and since
everything is so high that no
dimensional yeah you would basically
have an agent that would stand in front
of the the television for forever and
these are problems that are like real
humans sorry no problem and these are
kind of problems which are being
addressed I'm or partially addressed by
my current approaches but but they kind
of and that's what interests me and very
much ignore like the the multi scenario
where for example in the fish cities I
think you can see that there is some
form of information transmission between
the fish we're without actually explicit
communication they Telegraph a certain
information about goal rewarding States
in the world or in the tank in which
they behave and yeah that's something I
I feel like is under treated and could
be treated more do you think something
like intelligence itself is an emergent
property of groups that do that or or is
it you know or can it be achieved by a
single agent or something like this yeah
so I recently watched a talk by 12k depe
who's really who's leading the
multi-agent efforts that be mind and in
his talk he spoke about the social
intelligence hypothesis and they have
been studies in theology which have
shown that for example I think it's it's
the size of the neocortex
correlates very strongly with the group
size and one example of this or I think
Jim pansies which happen
extraordinary bait in your aquatics and
they live in in in big groups so there's
this hypothesis that essentially living
in groups and forces a certain
evolutionary pressure on the group to
develop cognitive skills like theory of
minds and empathy and all these very
abstract terms I would say and this
hypothesis is sort of beautiful I'm not
sure how much I believe in it
of course they are also examples of
other species that that live on their
own and have pretty big new qualities
and or at least pretty big brains and
yeah I think definitely explicitly
modeling other agents as part of the
environment it is definitely definitely
something that can act as a natural
curriculum right as in enough ago I also
in StarCraft and if you think of these
big projects it seems fairly plausible
that you need some form of modality
agent setting to to really create
intelligence and there are multiple
reasons for that one of them is that the
multi agent setting helps in in or at
least the self place setting helps
oftentimes in in exploration so that
means that having an agent that kind of
is on par in terms of skill level and
exploiting against that agent can be a
form of exploitation since the other
agent is getting better at the same time
and you kind of learn from from from
beating and also evolving opponent you
said some really interesting things
there and and one thing was this notion
of empathy and consciousness because
that that's when we start getting into
the esoteric seer and shellay I'm only
allowed to say his name four times so I
think that's two now and you get he said
he said their emotions guide behavior
generation and they could be part of an
intelligent system and you also said
something interesting which is to what
extent is intelligence externalized
let's let's cover that first well this
also kind of relates to the whole
economics background right so I think
something that surely also talks about
and also Michael Jordan talks a lot
about
this concept of of markets being
intelligent systems trained where you
have multiple agents interacting in this
interaction like for example supply and
demand and really exhibits intelligence
which is not yea something we we
directly associate with with a single
brain or a single individual so yeah I
think it's probably yeah a different
aspect or a different dimension of
intelligence that can only be captured
in the multi agent setting because shall
I pointed out that we don't really
recognize evolution and markets as being
intelligent even though they are in in
some you know by Israel his own
framework more intelligent and more
open-ended than than things that we
might think of as being intelligent yeah
and of course markets do not have a
consciousness they don't feel anything
they don't have any emotions yeah is
consciousness
attention emotion are very yeah these
terms have very different meanings for
everyone in this in this conversation
right now right and oftentimes I have
tried to shy away from from these
because it's pretty hard to talk or if
you have a discussion that kind of is
fruitful or at least that's my opinion
because oftentimes arguments kind of
assume that people have the same
definition of things right and often
times they don't
Jannik says something really interesting
which because one of the things that
chalet defines and his framework is is
the kind of separation between a skill
program and some system of intelligence
and Yannick made the observation that
you could argue that the deep mind
system was intelligent because of the
gestalt because of the deep mind team
because of all of the programmers that
created the system and you can really
kind of widen the the definition but you
also mentioned Daniel Kahneman's work as
well and when we talk about intelligence
we spend a lot of time talking about
system 1 and system 2 with your work on
multi agent reinforcement learning and
some of the successes of deep mind and
so on to what extent do you think those
successes are intelligent you
within the context of system 1 and
system 2 all right well yeah I think if
you were a sailor working a deep mind
you would reasonably articulate their
system as being system 2 because it has
a framework of reasoning and planning
and explicit knowledge and various
things that are present in system to not
system what and of course they would be
reaching a little bit but where do you
you know put the chips down on the table
on on that dichotomy so I think right
now in mentoring we're sort of at a
point where much of the learning rules
are fundamentally a correlational so for
example minimizing temporal difference
errors basically go back to your
Pavlovian conditioning in the sense that
you have a conditioned stimulus and an
unconditioned stimulus and I think when
when yoshua bengio talks about moving
from system one to system two there's
most definitely something something
there I think there are many pieces of
works which kind of try to address
certain parts of this problem so there's
a really brilliant paper on machine
theory of mind by me of what I mean
events and and a group of Matthew bottom
it gets a deep mind but they all kind of
are very fragmented so one paper
addresses one problem of higher
cognition and another one addresses
another problem and actually putting
these pieces together and formulating a
theory of deep learning that and
capsules all of these is really tough
really hard but something that's
probably gonna come or it has to come
how do you see this I mean you probably
also have a lot of opinions all of you
three guys well I think what one of the
big things that Chalet brought into the
discussion is the anthropocentric view
of intelligence and whether whether you
should think of intelligence as just
being a kind of collection of human
priors and being able to do things in
the human scope of tasks and there seems
to be an in stark contrast to the single
agent Universal view of intelligence I
think that's that's certainly an appoint
of discussion but I think there is some
skepticism shared between us three about
as surely points out the degree to which
the deep mind innovations are
intelligent and how much of it is just
bought with a training and skills and so
on but yeah Anakin Connor I think this
is a good time to segue to to you guys
what are your thoughts on this I see two
themes with the the show lady and the
function of intelligence being Pryor's
experienced and then measured by
generalization difficulty I think you
know I don't have any problem trading
off priors for experience with respect
to calling the system intelligent but
then I think measuring the
generalization difficulty is something
that I you know I don't think that's a
easy task to do you know whether it's
like I've recently been looking at these
Auto regressive generative models that
do a really good job of modeling P of X
because they have this conditional chain
of probabilities and makes it easy to do
that and maybe that's the way of doing
some kind of added distribution
detection to do a generalization
difficulty metric or maybe it's some
kind of you know other composition of
underlying rules but I think that part
of the equation of the general
organization difficulty is is the
hardest part of using this function of
priors experience and generalization
difficulty to measure intelligence but
then another thing like more on the kind
of esoteric ideas that I think a lot of
this I think about how consciousness
might emerge in a machine learning
system and whether a self-driving car
that say would have like a hundred
billion parameters all this data and
then this complicated architecture or
like a multi agent reinforcement
learning system which one of these two
are going to be like conscious first say
like and to me consciousness as a
function of attending on myself
attending on my own representations as
well as my actions and then kind of this
externalized knowledge because I you
know I communicate in my own head in the
same language that I communicate with
you guys and so I think that
externalized knowledge is a huge role in
my consciousness so that's kind of my
thoughts on these two pretty big ideas I
think of intelligence I think what makes
what makes humans that intelligent at
least one thing that is sort of sort of
in RL already is this notion of
planning and but but it's kind of more
human centric planning I think human
humans do a lot of things and abstract
them to like navigation tasks so like if
you if you think how am I gonna prove
this mathematical theorem I'm pretty
sure what you what most humans do is
they'll abstract it into some sort of
three or two dimensional navigation task
which okay I can get from there to there
and from there to there like even the
language of proofs is structured in a
way where it's like you're navigating
some kind of landscape and I think these
this is widely underused by RL so far
and it's questioned whether we have to
use it like humans are just good at that
because we're adapted to that and maybe
it's not it's not the it's not the
ultimate way to reach intelligence but I
think you know that's I we still have we
still have a lot to do there and then
with respect to measuring intelligence
I'm not you know sure especially if if
when Shirley says something like you
have to just write down all the priors
that you use like it's like oh yeah just
write them write them all down
although the prior knowledge that you
used to solve this problem like no know
anyone who's tried using an automatic
proof solver knows that even to prove
like some Pythagorean theorem or
something you have to specify two pages
of preconditions such that the problem
is exactly specified it's just
impossible and I think this this
implicit knowledge of the world
knowledge of the world is something
maybe that the RL agents lack so far
yeah but I'm not sure has anyone of you
and look at the results from the air
ERC's challenge or is it still running I
I haven't been keeping up to date that
is one thing that I really want to do
because I think we could make a video
just on the a RC challenge I just
watched the annex fourth installment on
the measure of intelligence where he
spoke about the a RC challenge and gives
you ten what are my thoughts about
intelligence and one of the big things
that surely picks up on is this concept
of generalization he argues their
generalization is entirely missing from
everywhere from everyone else's did
there
Nishan but then he goes on at the end of
his paper to suggest that essentially if
you could come up with a domain-specific
language and if you could capture all of
the human priors and in essentially
programming code then you've solved
intelligence so that seems to contradict
what he was saying before about
intelligence and this is a philosophical
question because GPT 3 appears
intelligence appears intelligent because
it's memorized so much stuff on the
internet and if it were possible to
write a program that would encapsulate
all of the human priors that would be
able to do useful things in all
situations would that to be intelligent
and what are the other things that
intelligent systems have well I think
that consciousness is orthogonal to
intelligence and intelligent systems
seem to have some higher-level explicit
knowledge reasoning planning
verbalization but the thing that Yannick
commented on in his video is you always
have the AI effect so every time you
solve something with AI people will say
that's not really intelligent it's
taking a shortcut or you've just
explicitly programmed it and with that
AI effects manifest itself the entire
way even when you actually solve
something which by all definitions is
intelligent it will still be something
that isn't intelligent it's a good
question just to D to the AARC challenge
I believe it's ended the results are out
the winner has managed to solve some of
the tasks but not a lot so it's still
largely an unsolved challenge and I
believe there is no look if I recall
correctly and I might be completely
wrong but there is no learning in the
winning solution it is really this
approach of a kind of a domain-specific
language trying to reason what the used
priors in the in the in the task or I
might do that but I've also heard there
was a good solution using are these like
that the game of life things cellular
automata yeah so so there are a number
of approaches is pretty cool actually to
just watch the solution like I've
personally I believe that this a or C
challenge has very very little to do
with intelligence but I just find it a
cool challenge as such like it's
completely different and
yeah I think that's a good question
though is does it have nothing to do
with intelligence or maybe maybe it does
I was reading your article about the
measure of intelligence on your blog and
you quoted chalet and he put a tweet out
at the beginning saying for those of you
that are struggling with the AARC
challenge you know write some simple
programs to solve the things in the test
set and then abstract it into a
domain-specific language and if you're
reasonably smart within a few weeks
you'll have something that will solve
let's say 5% of the challenge which is
in in the private a RC dataset it's
almost as if he's alluding to the fact
that of course it's not really
intelligence you've just written a bunch
of code yourself or really is it I think
in the beginning there was a lot of hope
I think also from Julia and kind of
coming up with a solution that really
banks on neural program does this
basically exactly that kind of trying to
learn the programs then that's all these
more high-level tasks classes but it's
yarmulkes right then it seems like this
really hasn't succeeded yet I tried some
things in the beginning but I felt like
it really tackled a lot of aspects of
intelligence that are right now not even
closely being tackled by 57 sorry games
for example right and I'm not sure this
is agree I don't think this is
intelligence it's a very different
perspective friend or would you disagree
Yannick no absolutely it's I mean of
course any like an intelligent system
could solve these things but to me it's
like there are probably more ways than
building something that people would
call intelligent that solves these
things and I am more interested in the
actual solutions like there's gonna be
super interesting once someone solves it
to see how yeah maybe something two
friends of mine and Matthew Crosby and
they have been working on the animal AI
Olympics I don't know if you have seen
this and I feel like that also addresses
a lot of topics that are not necessarily
addressed by the a or C challenge like
embodiments and yeah certain aspects of
memory and
you can only get from a lot more complex
environment I think I spoke about unity
in the beginning and I feel like we're
really added on where the intersection
between complex game engines and
reinforcement learning or learning more
general is it's going to start taking
off I just wanna maybe tap into your
knowledge of neuroscience these kind of
things just ask a quick question I have
about thinking about human priors and
how we can look at human priors I think
of things like face permanence that
babies are born knowing to look at the
face and you know assign some extra
focus to that as being maybe like a
weight initialization that causes you to
do that task and we can initialize our
neural networks with these different
tasks and then blackbox input-output
tests if they can do these tasks well
then I think about other things that are
maybe more like of a structural prior
like how we have say the hippocampus is
where we create memories so it's like is
it like this wait initialization or is
it like this structure or am i gun
so first of all as with economics I'm
also not an expert or a total expert in
neuroscience or anything like that but I
fully agree that searching for the right
enough devices from neuroscience is is
super important and there's a lot of
work also being quoted by a by Shelley
on core knowledge in all these kind of
hard priors that seem to be somewhat
genetically hardwired in in kids like
depth perception for example and all
these things that develop very very
early on and yeah
wait initialization is certainly one way
to think about it as as in the meta
learning context for example like model
agnostic meta learning another one is
definitely also structural inductive
biases like a convolution or an
intention area or something but I guess
there's also a lot that still has to be
explored like like lottery tickets for
example which somehow combined weight
initialization with and connectivity and
structural motives so yeah I think
that's that's a good way to think about
it it's a it's a nice segue into into
this article right if this super lengthy
and very thorough art
about the lottery ticket hypothesis
because you know since its inception of
course like a lot of work has been has
been done and it's so incredibly
fascinating that that maybe just from
your perspective do you have any do you
have any sort of if you had to formulate
the lottery ticket hypothesis in in your
view after all of this survey what would
be because we have already had you know
Jon Frankel on and gave give his
explanation but this is you know after
now years of work on it
is there is there like something from
your view where you could say okay I I
can formulate it somehow in a unifying
manner or in the manner that is most
interesting hmm
so I guess something when I started
getting into deep learning that always
struck me as weird was that there's this
argument that over parameterize ation is
really the the essence of being making
deep networks burnable right so I think
Jana Kuhn has this nice visualization
where you're in a 1d space you have your
weight being in a local minimum and then
if you add dimensions you have your
weight kind of escape that local minimum
right and I think that's kind of a
heuristic or hand-wavy explanation for
how we train or why we're able to change
and deep nets and the lottery ticket
hypothesis yeah it kind of really puts
this heuristic or this yeah weird
explanation into question and it kind of
states that it's possible to Train
sparse neural networks and to overcome
essentially in these local optima if you
find a sub Network from a dense full
network that is initialized correctly
essentially and that allows you to
traverse the optimization or in the
weight space in a certain way that it
makes it trainable yeah and I think
something that very very much excites me
about this empirical phenomenon is that
there are way more open questions right
now
based on it and actually answers and I
think in the blog post I try to kind of
allow people to get a rough overview of
the literature that's out there so for
anyone who wants to get started in this
field and I also kind of state my my
open questions or questions I would like
to see answers to and since I'm not
working actively in this field this is
something that I really really hope to
do you have people kind of provide
insights over next years I love the way
that you gave yonder Coons argument of
you start off in one dimension and I
think it would be really good to give
our viewers intuitions on what's going
on and that's a good one so you're
saying that the more dimensions you have
the more it's almost like the more
directions you have to go in order to
get out of your local minimum so that's
one intuition another intuition that
that Yannick said on his video was that
it's about sub networks resonating with
the algorithm I'm not sure if that's
compatible with the first intuition or
not
so the it's a bit like these things a
lumps of clay and there are so many sub
networks that can pull on the SGD
algorithm what what kind of intuition
would would you give to folks so we have
resonating is a really nice from a
tougher I guess since since something
that I found really fascinating when I
really read the first lottery ticket
paper was that it's not that you're just
finding a network of weights that is
very well initialized which has already
learned what what an edge detector is
for example but these weights actually
move more right and and then your normal
normally distributed weights that you
get from initialization and yeah this
this kind of idea of resonating as as
non-technical as it might be is yeah
it's something that kind of falls in in
this observation right so yeah I think
it's a good good way of putting it I
don't recall saying that honestly so
this is not this is Tim's idea that's
very good I forgot it so it's still your
credit
one way of saying it a slightly
different way is guardrails so you could
say that the sub-networks provide
guardrails for the optimization
algorithm but the the intuition seems to
be that by having a lot of parameters it
helps find the best solution it helps
the optimization algorithm a training
time but clearly these sub networks you
know all of that parameterization is not
needed in inferencing well did the the
thing like they thought that I guess
everyone has when hearing the lottery
ticket hypothesis paper is like oh oh so
we don't need all of the parameters
right like can we like this is great we
can just you know we don't need all this
stuff and now let's just assume we can
we have we will have like sparse
accelerators and all which I think even
if if we have the lottery ticket it
doesn't really help much because we you
know we don't have sparse GPUs for
sparsity and so on but let's assume we
had we'd still need to know which sub
network is the important one at the
beginning of training right do you from
so from your survey from your entire
survey what kind of work is there how
far along are we to be able to decide at
the beginning of training or maybe you
know after an epoch or so which ones are
the winning tickets and do we do we
still need all the weights well I think
you also have a video and the synaptic
flow pick around one of them yes from
from so you can good yeah or from the
lap of Silicon booty and yeah honestly I
don't have any practical experience with
this I would hope that we're close to to
having something that identifies tickets
early on like the first paper I reviewed
finds tickets by by using a very
aggressive kind of learning scheme using
latched learning rates I think they also
use no precision training and they they
claim to be able to find early bird
tickets after a few apples by showing
essentially that the pruning mask
changes little after doing during that
essentially okay but this is also only
in the case where they prune
entire filters and not single weights
and they use essentially a scoring based
on the batch norm scaling factor I think
so it's a very kind of different setting
than the classical setting that you're
having a lot a good hypothesis and yeah
but the synaptic flow paper really
excites me really takes takes a
theoretical argument and transforms it
into an algorithm that's actually
actionable and I guess a lot of work
from so you can goalie from the group
uses these insights from more of a
statistical physics world here to kind
of in the real world so yeah but
something that actually personally
excites me a lot more than trying to
find tickets very early on is this idea
of okay we might not ever get there but
we still have this working horse in
terms of iterative magnitude pruning
which allows us to find tickets in in
the vision context and potentially also
in other contexts and this idea of being
able to transfer them it's something
that I also talked about in this review
about the paper by Ally Morris ranked in
his group at face book a I'm and yeah
this is something I really find
fascinating way I feel like there's a
lot of potential of actually using this
huge amount of compute as being used to
to come up with these tickets to
actually be reused in in different
settings by by providing the form of a
lottery ticket initialization could you
just quick there's there's a couple of
things that we will go through the
article logically in a second you just
mentioned this the synaptic pruning I
watched
Yonex video about that and I must admit
I didn't completely grasp it at the time
because it was it was sold as something
which was free you know you don't need
to train the network you could learn
some kind of salience II on these
weights and it seems to avoid this kind
of mode collapse where sometimes were
pruning if you no longer have any
connections between the layers then
you've broken the neural network
essentially but I didn't completely
grasp that at the time so can one of you
introduced that methodology yawning do
you want to go first I think your video
isn't too old yeah well well the the
whole pruning thing I thought was a bit
gimmicky because essentially what
they're saying is if I am setting out to
prune 99% of my weights and I just do it
by magnitude
I might run into the difficulty like
into this case where I just prune an
entire layer and then I don't have any
connections anymore right that's so so
that's bad right but I that you know
current algorithms would actually do
that and if so you could just enforce
that you would always have to have a
valid at least one valid connection from
the start to the end of the network so
that's kind of gimmicky but what they
want to say is sort of a good pruning
algorithm should naturally not want to
prune weights that where you would have
no connection from the beginning to the
end so that's if they're basically
arguing that a good principle of pruning
should you know if you push it to the
maximum it should keep you know it at
the very maximum at the end it should
keep one single connection alive from
the beginning layer to the end layer and
if a pruning algorithm doesn't fulfill
that then it's already at that pruning
algorithm and then they show that their
pruning algorithm is the only one out of
current ones that actually does this
naturally now there are many more that
do this naturally but that's that's one
thing I found it a bit gimmicky but it's
it's you know part of their argument why
their algorithm makes sense I don't know
what are your thoughts Robert so the way
how they formalized or yeah stayed there
their algorithm is based on this notion
of a maximal critical compression and
this is this idea okay you want to
compress very very strongly but at the
same time in a fully connected layer you
would want to keep that one weight that
kind of lets either activations flow or
gradients flow backwards right and yeah
I think that's a really good way how to
do it you formalize this problem of
initializing or of pruning at
initialization they have much of math
which shows that this is essentially
what you want to do but the intuition is
kind of trivial and I agree with the
n-type and this kind of seems a bit
gimmicky and but I also believe they
they are not able to prune as
aggressively as you would be in a
lottery ticket situation when they do it
at the beginning right which it's it's
the cool thing right they they basically
look at the network at the beginning and
they say I'll look
based on how basically they just have to
input a input data point of ones like of
all ones
so you just in feed like a constant
signal and you observe how the signal
travels through the network and just by
that you prune away so this is a lot of
evidence that it's kind of more about
these lottery tickets some are really
about how the signal is able to flow
through the network and and and we want
to sort of keep just where the signal is
able to flow and that already will
result in a network that's very
trainable but they're still as Robert
says they're still like so many open
questions and I feel every paper that
answers one raises five new ones which
is why this is a cool field exactly
that's that's how science should be
right I think what Jonathan said in your
podcast in the senator you need to have
hypotheses over which you can iterate
and gradually kind of move our
understanding hmm so normalizing flow is
like a series of transformations on say
the random distribution that turns into
the data distribution for a generative
model right how does the normalizing
flow connect with this pruning idea is
it about the weight matrices in like the
way they transform it has to like be
this series of invertible
transformations well it is a hard
connection to make but I guess as is I
guess it's so in the normalizing flow
generative model what you always have to
ensure is that you can do the inverse
function right so because you want to
normalize the flow that's that's how you
you have to calculate the Jacobian and
therefore you are only allowed to make
these building blocks where you can
actually invert the function hey I think
the lottery tickets it's sort of the
same where you want to keep the
connections around that give you a good
backward signal but in the normalizing
flow you sort of do it by construction
where you say I'm only going to use like
these layers these very special layers
that allow me to whatever happens
calculate the inverse and in the lottery
ticket hypothesis is more like you say I
know there is like a subnet
work where my where my signal flows
really well forward and back and I'm
gonna find it right but yeah the
connection is interesting I've never
thought about any of any of that okay
should we have a quick helicopter flyby
on the article so it's a beautiful
article it's got some high-level
headings here so it talks about pruning
in general and essentially the why here
is that it gives better generalization
it improves the memory footprint it has
good implications for energy in storage
and latency and you can use it on mobile
devices and so on
could we just cover off the sparsity
thing because it's not really sparse we
just have a mask matrix which can zero
off certain weight so how does this
actually translate into a smaller
footprint do we need to reconstruct it
in a new data structure afterwards so I
guess you spoke about this topic with
Jonathan as well and then the real
speedups are kind of a questionable at
this point and then there's a lot of fat
where engineering going on right now
where where people try to I guess
exploit sparsity but I think it down
there somewhere I also have written
something about yeah a structured versus
unstructured pruning and like these
ideas of luck sparsity and it's really
important what and how you proven in
terms of actually gaining these these
speed ups right so just as more I guess
their motivation for future kind of
aspirations of sparse neural network
research right well this is a beautiful
image I mean could you give us a quick
rolling commentary on on this sure I
guess the whole idea of the
visualization is that this is not needed
but yeah I guess they're in in the field
of pruning over parametrized function
functions there are four but probably
even more main questions to answer and
one of them is what do you actually want
to prove so you want to prove in a
single weights you want to prune four
neurons you want to prune four full
channels of a of a convolutional layer
and then there's the question do you
want to proven locally so that means you
Huna constant fraction of weights on
yours from a specific layer or do you
allow global pruning that kind of just
asks ok I want to proven X percent of my
network take these X percent from from
whatever layers you want to take them
from so this is the the first pillar the
the what prune right and then there are
different algorithms that kind of try to
do to identify the the importance of a
specific weight or a specific structure
in that network based on certain scores
and one score which is used in the
lottery ticket hypothesis or in
iterative magnitude pruning is this
magnitude based score so that says that
weights which are big in terms of
magnitude are likely to be more
important for for for for you neural
network and then there are a bunch of
other ways how to prune and I think even
even Jonathan Frankel says that
magnitude or iterative magnitude pruning
is only one way which might be very very
inefficient or is very very inefficient
and so there's a bunch of research to be
done in that point
another question is you want to prune
directly before you start training
anything the alternative is that you
train the key prune during training and
then you can simply prune after training
and then simply fine-tune a little bit
yeah and you can finally you think about
how often you want to do this if you
want to just do this once or if you want
to kind of iterate and fine-tune over
and over and thereby shape or kind of
more aggressively pruning the amount of
weights in your network ok wonderful I
mean this is testament to how well you
distill down this topic so you framed it
beautifully at the top of the article
and then the rest of the article is a
tour de force in chronological order of
how the locket that the lottery ticket
came to be and some of these successive
you know kind of improvements on it so
that the the original lottery ticket
hypothesis is stated here then so a
randomly initialized dense neural
network contains a sub network that is
initialized such that when trained in
isolation it can
that's the test accuracy of the original
network after training for it most the
same number of iteration so this was
last year and it goes on to introduce
this iterative magnitude pruning
algorithm so would you like to give us a
quick run-through of that I'm sure so
the main idea is that you prune based on
magnitudes and you start with a weight
initialization that will use 0 you train
until convergence or until some early
stopping criterion is is fulfilled and
then you evaluate the magnitudes of the
wavelets and rank them and you prune and
shape off a certain percentage and that
gives you this weighting mask and one
and once you've pruned you go back to
the initialization and simply mask away
the weights that you pruned after the
first training run and then you continue
training and then you iterate over this
procedure and each time you you shape
off or you mask away an additional P or
s percent of the weights and the lottery
ticket hypothesis uses this this one
method iterative measure magnitude print
pruning to search for four lottery
tickets so for these sparse neural
network initializations
which are called winning tickets that
perform on par or better than than the
full dense network and yeah that's
basically yeah so there's a couple of
that kind of take-home points from this
the paper clearly demonstrated that over
parameterisation wasn't necessary for
successful training and it helps to
provide a combinatorial explosion of
possible sub networks and this iterative
thing is interesting as well because
there is a noisy relationship between
the magnitude of the weights and the the
salience I mean I think you made the
comment in here that it seems to
contradict the concept of L to weight
regular regularization because that
seems to suggest that having a high
magnitude on the weight is a bad thing
not a good thing so doing it iteratively
seems to reduce that noise or that layer
of in
direction between the salience e of the
weight although I think I gotta add
there that I believe that all the
networks and the paper I actually
already trained without e regularization
right so that the final weights are
already kind of shaped in a certain way
by the regular risers so yeah okay now
there are four beautiful images here
let's talk through them so the first one
I think is showing that what would
happen if you just randomly prune
weights and how the performance would
deteriorate can you talk us through
these yeah so this is I think the the
very first plot in the very first
lottery ticket paper which essentially
shows on an endless using a common kind
of architecture called Lynette that you
essentially can't prune too much unless
or until the performance drops
significantly right and yeah so the the
non dashed line is is the Train Network
I think and the the dashed line is a
random initialization basically that is
reinitialized at that pruned state and
then trained until convergence again I
say and it and it drops off
significantly when there's about two
point nine percent I think on the panel
B this is showing the the version with
the lottery tickets and it's showing
that the network that for example is
pruned to twenty one percent of the
weights is converging to a higher
accuracy faster than the original
network with a hundred percent of the
waste which I think is this one here
that's absolutely mind-blowing isn't it
I mean still a mess and Lynette but yeah
it's I guess this is the key motivation
behind the first paper well it's kind of
the the cherry on top right it's not not
only can you can you prune at the
beginning and still retain the same
accuracy is actually the fact that you
do get better which is you know it
raises entire new questions of like
signal-to-noise ratio like you can can
make the case that probably if you have
this sub network then you have a much
better signal and all the other
connections would actually just kind of
this
DRAQ do during training things like this
so yeah it's it's it's all it's all I
guess still up for grabs for a lot of
it's still up for grabs okay so in in
the next paper that we talked about that
Robert talks about in the article there
seems to be a limitation on the original
paper it was restricted to fairly small
scale tasks it didn't seem to work on
some of the larger network architectures
and this as we are going to learn has
something to do with the stability in
the earlier phases of neural network
training and this paper introduces this
concept of rewinding could you introduce
that Robert yeah so I guess in the first
paper already like they also looked at
safe attend I'm not sure if they
actually also looked at cipher 100
nonetheless in these kind of more
ambitious computer vision tasks the the
original claim iterative Magna tree
pruning algorithm failed in identifying
winning tickets and what they had to do
the air to it you still get winning
tickets is to use a learning rate
warm-up and to essentially start with a
highway a learning rate I think go down
and then go up again and this was kind
of unsatisfying I think and then there
was some follow-up work by by other
people who showed that this this doesn't
scale when you rewind or when you set
back the weights due to the initial
weights and at iteration zero
essentially and this rewinding idea then
kind of asks if we if we wouldn't rewind
or if we wouldn't go back to iteration
zero but we would simply kind of take
the final train weights then then we
would obviously get something that's
that someone performant but if we kind
of gradually go back more and more and
rewind to an iteration which is kind of
closer to zero than to the final
iteration then at which point can we can
we actually get a winning tickets or a
matching ticket in this case because
we're no longer really talking about
yeah a lottery in that sense since since
since the weights to which we rewind are
actually
ready trained for for a little while so
yeah this rewinding idea then kind of
allowed this concept of iterative
magnitude pruning to to yield weights I
guess there are capable of of showing
similar performance as the the full kind
of lottery ticket hypothesis so this how
much I'm sorry
how much design needs to go into
scheduling the learning rate and the
role of having some kind of warm start
with respect to this kind of process
boom I personally don't know I don't
know how Jonathan Franco who came up
with this this learning rate schedule in
the first place have you asked him in
the interview actually or what's that a
debate okay no Jonathan says that it's
really interesting to look back at
version one of the archives paper and
and I fully agree it's it's like a
really miraculous development
yeah but often times in general in
machine learning papers I would really
really want to see like a kind of
timeline of what was tried what failed
and then then she learned from from the
failures as well right because yeah
whenever you start a new project you ask
yourself I'm probably gonna have 9,000
hypotheses which are gonna fail but
maybe someone else has already tried
them so can I actually benefit from from
that but yeah so I don't know where you
just haven't done it right if you
[Laughter]
they're just a few lottery tickets out
there scientists also you can't
replicate my experiments you haven't you
just haven't done it right that code
yeah but I also believe that this
rewinding paper is actually it's it's
only published on archive and I think
that I'm the full reference that
Jonathan uses is actually the one on the
linear mode connectivity images very
much yeah related to this idea of okay
when do these tickets actually arise and
what are the mechanisms or the
ingredients or for what for why this is
the case
yeah I think the linear motion activity
paper is really interesting let's
quickly just change this one off so this
but this was the one this year from
render and Frankel comparing the various
different approaches to pruning so
comparing in a fine-tuning wait
rewinding and learning rate rewinding
and I think the the findings from this
where there wait rewinding and
Retraining outperforms simple
fine-tuning and learning rates rewinding
outperforms wait rewinding and rate
rewinding networks is the the
state-of-the-art
method at the moment yeah right right
but at initialization right if so it's
if it's a matching ticket the learning
rate rewind is still better right on the
third point is the you still want to
rewind the learning we're not learning
rate instead when you're when you're
going back to say K instead of zero
yeah and it's true I believe okay yeah I
would have to look it up but I think so
yeah okay so this next one I think this
is the uber paper I think that they got
some flack for this didn't they they
were saying that the sign of the wait
seemed to be quite important and so on
could you give us a quick intro to this
yeah I gotta give a huge shout out to
Jonathan Wright because I asked him for
feedback before I published this this
post and he was so kind to it to
actually provide it and yeah we we spoke
briefly about this paper and because
what he said or what he laid it on
showed in the paper called the early
phase of neural network training is that
it's actually pretty hard and for him
impossible to replicate this finding on
the science and yeah so I guess the main
motivation behind this this uber paper
is actually keeper into how much can you
put Erb these lottery tickets to while
still remaining there there kind of
capabilities in that sense and they
perform a bunch of different commands to
do so and yeah one one really cool
takeaway that I got out of that paper
was this idea of thinking of pruning as
a form of training so they argue that at
the weights that are being shaped off by
either make or by iterative magnitude
prove any pruning weights which it would
have gone to zero anyways so what you're
essentially doing by pruning them away
is your kind of speeding up the learning
process so they were destined to go to
zero so let's just mask them away so
that the learning process can can focus
essentially on what's relevant yeah
and then there's this idea of of a super
mask which which is also pretty exciting
which is essentially based on the
observation that only using the mask
without actually training anything but
simply your reinitializing allows you to
to already get above chance performance
on uncertain classification
classification tasks and and this kind
of already highlights this idea that the
mask itself can be a form of bias that
already gives the network a certain
structure that is performing fairly well
and I don't know you probably also all
have read where you know there's this
paper by by David Homme and Adam Gaia on
these weight agnostic neural networks
and this yeah exactly that paper but
there are even better visualizations I
gotta say like one of my my big
inspirations for for doing doing and
doing these visualizations is definitely
David and in this paper they they kind
of have a similar take away as this idea
of super masks where where they look at
network architectures or inductive
biases more broadly I guess that are
performing well agnostic to you to to
the weight that that you use so they
only I think even used a single weight
and yeah these super masks which OH uber
are used for are also capable of
performing agnostic to essentially the
initialization that you use sample I
guess for given that the fixed masks
yeah I also wanted to talk about this
paper was hidden in a randomly weighted
neural network and then their most
recent fallen work super mass and
superposition so in a similar way with
training this learn mass they're gonna
use this thing the straight-through
estimator and they're gonna train the
mask only so it's random weights and
they're training the masks so I've been
thinking a lot and then so in this paper
what they're doing now is it's a
continual learning thing where you have
a new task and you're going to
go find the Super mask within this
randomly weighted Network that is best
suited for this task so I think it's
pretty interesting for continual
learning to just you know find this new
neural network within this dense
architecture and not have to retrain
weights I think it could be you know
it's a pretty interesting thing to think
about how you can just train these masks
so I'm just curious like how do you
think more the difference between
training a mask which is kind of like a
binary Network like why wouldn't just a
network with ones and zeros I you know
perform better but I guess it's because
you still have the kind of lower
precision weights but to me it's like
kind of interesting to think about the
difference between a binary neural
network and then a like a learned mask
oh that's absolutely fascinating so this
idea of learning the binary mask instead
of the weights or in addition to the
weights yeah instead of the weights and
they even talked about yeah it's kind of
like a differentiable architecture
search in a way where you could have a
continuous relaxation on the weights in
a way you mean and make them
floating-point numbers like make the
masks floating-point numbers and then
train them like they're just floating
point numbers I'm not sure but I'm kind
of cynical about these guys mask things
which which essentially what they're
saying is oh you don't get to actually
change the weight but you get to change
which weights you combine which it seems
to me like to be almost the same thing
as training the weights except you get
to decide how much you want to mix a
predefined set of weights instead of
being able to adjust them directly so
I'm a bit you know in I'm a bit between
opinions in in the case I still haven't
seen something that really convinces me
that this is something new and then yeah
it's like Oh could we relax the binary
weights to maybe something related to
two that I oftentimes feel like yeah a
little bit unsatisfied in the sense that
the
papers don't really look at the masks or
I don't know this paper but oftentimes
they don't really look at the masks and
and what these masks may encode so for
me it's more interesting to look into
okay what kind of structural biases
might there be encoded in in these masks
and can we use them them for for other
things and that's where I guess the
weight agnostic neural network paper
kind of kind of leaks and provide some
some more or better interpretation in
terms of very simple kind of policies I
think for for cat Paul and like easier
reinforcement learning problems yeah
but nonetheless I guess this the
superior massed paper kind of is a
really nice transition yeah to this more
I guess inductive bias perspective on
lottery tickets fine okay well let's do
one of the most exciting bits now and
that is introducing the linear mode
connectivity paper is that this this is
absolutely incredible who wants to have
a stab at this I think I have a sense of
it but so it's like this idea that you
tree why no weights
it's like the ordering of the data
batches is gonna change how the weights
come out if you give it like six cats
and four dogs and two horses compared to
their so so multiple to obviously or
compared to like frogs and airplanes and
see far 10 you're gonna get different
weights as a result of that so it's
saying can you when you're sampling
these different sources are data to
update the networks what is the
difference between the networks and can
you linearly interpolate between the
waste and this is kind of the issue that
I have with it a bit is this kind of
alpha 1 minus alpha where you're just
kind of averaging the weights together
to get to the new network I think it's a
little I don't know it seems bizarre to
me to average out the parameters of a
neural network and this kind of linear
way but it the idea is that if you can
average out these weights such that it
still performs okay then they're going
to be stable and I think the result of
this stability means that I'm not sure
if I understand what you get out of
being stable well we can't can we eat
them just on that there's a wonderful
image here showing the instability as a
function of training so it seems to show
is I think on the the earlier versions
Jonathan was having trouble making it
work on larger architectures and I think
the implication here is that it was to
do with the instability in the earlier
phases of training and there's some
argument that at least some of that
instability is because of the random
sample selection in SGD yeah I guess
that's the really fascinating insight
right then this iteration to which you
have to rewind to obtain a matching
ticket and is exactly at the iteration
at which you can achieve stability and
this kind of perspective of connecting
the the learning dynamics with the event
or the emergence of lottery tickets is
yeah is something that I find extremely
inspiring and what's this thing here so
you train for a bit and then you split
and then you kind of interpolate between
the weights of these two splits and it's
showing instability and in the middle so
what's going on that so basically
exactly what you just described in the
sense that you linearly pull what if the
other and if you if you wouldn't do this
on the one extreme you would just take
the 1 train weights and then the other
you take the the other train fully train
weights then you would have strong
performance on both of them but what you
would hope to have is a mode
connectivity which which we would
represent most ability essentially right
when you pull them over and you don't
exhibit too strong of a decrease in
performance yeah I guess it's something
about like how far back can you rewind
can you you know if you rewind the
weights a duration 5 and then you want
to you know finish off with it is is it
stable with this metric and then if not
don't you know you've rewound too far is
that a good application of it maybe sure
okay so so the idea is is you should
train for a little bit first before you
start doing any kind of pruning wait for
the stability to manifest as a basically
okay let me see yeah what's happening in
this panel see it
you can see in the middle of regime that
essentially only iterative magnitude
pruning is what actually yields these
these stable and matching chickens and
then in the final regime where you prune
away even more and this stability also
kind of arises again later at a later
point in time okay so essentially this
is again kind of another way of saying
that iterative magnitude pruning and and
the rewinding iteration are deeply
connected to this notion of stability so
you can use this stability to say you
know I I've pruned too far back and or
I've rebound too far back and now I know
there's no saving the network yeah
that's home garage yeah and this is then
the the follow-up paper I just spoke
about in the in the context of the of
the uber paper where they essentially
try to characterize the very very early
stages of neural network training by
essentially using these lottery tickets
as as a form of a hypothesis testing
engine almost right so they look at how
lottery tickets remain winning or
matching tickets remain winning in some
formal way giving giving different
iterations of rewinding and different
perturbations and here you can see just
just to the selection so I urge everyone
who's really interested in the lottery
ticket hypothesis to to go pretty deep
on the appendix figure so oftentimes
there are and now two times as many
figures in the appendix of the paper
then then actually in the main paper and
they explore a bunch of perturbations
and this paper that I don't that I
didn't select to to make it into my blog
post since you gotta shave off right but
yeah here like a couple of them which
look at for example keeping keeping the
weights of a ticket and or keeping the
signs of the ticket weights essentially
and only changing the values why versus
like keeping both or yeah different
combinations of these and what you can
see is
that's not all of them remain stable
essentially when you do this form of
perturbation and in the paper they're a
bunch of hypotheses why why this might
be the case and yeah I guess it's it's
too much detail to really go through but
yeah the end just kind of most awesome
figure from from the whole paper is
probably this one which gives a rough
description of what's happening during
the very very early iterations of
chaining a ResNet 20 on on Sipho 10
right and you can see all these
different kind of developments in terms
of magnitudes of gradients and weight
space behavior and you have the main
question that kind of arises here is how
much of this actually transfers to other
settings runs to not only resonate 20
and Sipho 10 because ultimately it's
psyphon
but it's really not it's kind of
heuristic or visualization of what might
be be going on
so like what a quick takeaway be between
500 to 2,000 iterations you that's where
you can rewind and then 2000 plus is
when it's you know gonna saturate and
say it's 98 point one percent it's only
ever gonna get to ninety eight point one
one right so between 500 and 2000 or
like a quarter approximately the full
training at least is when you get to
start to do this at the scale of ResNet
20 on c for 10 yeah it's that's a good
interpretation I think yeah so so what
do you think about I guess you also have
a bunch of experience with training in
deep nets and yeah would you would you
think that some of these findings would
generalize to to your settings could I
just extend the questions that you said
that the extent to which this
generalizes do you guys think
intuitively that this is a function of
the number of parameters so what do you
think any network would exhibit this
kind of you know these regime changes
instability and trainee behavior
as a function of the architecture the
number of parameters how well does this
generalize or is this something which is
only specific to in this case ResNet 20
or safar 10 usually when I look at my
tens of boards and I look at at
gradients and gradient histograms and
distributions over time I can't really
make a lot of sense out of them I don't
know how that's the case for you like
everything looks sort of normal to me
and unless I've done something terribly
wrong so I think something we can talk
maybe later about when we talk about
different domains and how are these
results from main computer vision
transfer to domains which are more close
to my heart like reinforcement learning
I feel like things changed quite
significantly as soon as you change the
last function for example you might have
very different dynamics in terms of
learning right and all of these results
are mainly on multi class cross entropy
losses so I mean first learning when you
use like a mean square Pellman error
objective value based methods and you
have this whole idea of bootstrapping
and the agent generating their own data
the whole problem becomes highly non
stationary and everything might look
very different so that's something I'm
currently thinking about and yeah okay
given that we are reasonably short on
time yeah let's just think about which
ones are most interesting to talk about
his so you cover sin flow you cover the
paper that talks about their
generalization across data sets and
optimizers and then as you were just
talking about there's one here about
reinforcement learning in a natural
language processing where which one's
kind of resonate with you so we can try
to connect both of them right that's
okay I'm really excited about right now
so yeah like I just said most of these
or almost all of these results come from
from the domain of computer vision and
using resonates on image Nets I thought
ends I have 100 and so on and in this
paper by Alomar cross he looked at
whether or not you can find the ticket
on one date result and then use that
ticket as an initialization for for
another data set
and this kind of comes back to this idea
of tickets as inductive biases and one
thing that really excites me would be to
find a lottery ticket on a huge data set
right unlike kind of Google sale a
Google size data sets and then to see if
one could use such a ticket as an
initializer for for other tasks and you
kind of come up with something which I
call like a universal lottery ticket for
vision tasks and if that would be
personally possible if one could do the
same for for reinforcement learning or
for continuous control tasks or for
natural language processing and thereby
essentially kind of justify the huge
amount of computation that goes into
finding these lottery tickets and and
giving like your everyday user like me
your PhD student an initialization
scheme where you don't need to spend
tons of hours on training but you have
something that's already kind of capable
from the from the first place
this is somehow different from from just
doing transfer learning I sense you
transfer initializations and you don't
transfer essentially representations or
features and that's something that
excites me just just just linger on that
for a second because transfer learning
works incredibly well and it's tempting
to think that lottery tickets would
generalize more but would they actually
generalize less does transfer learning
work because there there is so much
parameterization in the network and
possibly the different sub networks are
firing in different domains so if you
distilled it down to one network one sub
Network what is that network it has that
just learned something so precisely that
it generalizes for that particular task
and less so one another task somewhere
else well yes that's a big question and
when I when I spoke to to Jonathan he
said that one actually has to be very
careful with these generalization
results and if you do minor things
different and it might be possible that
the lottery ticket is essentially kind
of able to generalize across the the
task or like the the problem that you've
all painted for right so
yeah I personally don't don't have an
answer to that question but yeah I would
be super interesting and I actually am
gonna have a massive scene who's gonna
look into interview questions whether or
not you can find a lottery ticket in the
reinforcement learning context or for
example in one great world and then see
whether or not that kind of transfers to
another one right and if these tickets
actually encode more abstract task
informations than simply yeah something
that's prone to to find edge detectors
fast or something like that
maybe this is a philosophical question
but do you think that a lottery ticket
is a kind of inductive prior or do you
think it's something which is learned
from experience to use chalets like ah
to me of priors and experience it is is
it lottery ticket basically a prior yeah
maybe maybe you can help me with that
but I don't I don't see a huge
difference between these two and when
you think on and I kind of in
philosophical terms I'm the evolutionary
timescales then these two things becomes
hard to disentangle in the sense that
evolution and has shaped a lot of our
cognitive skills and we're like our
visual cortex is extremely tailored to
our ecological niche and we were born
having already quite a lot of like
visual priors hard-coded from experience
that was gathered by our ancestors over
millions of years so how to disentangle
experience and prior priors once you
take this evolutionary ecological niche
perspective is something that's that's
not necessarily fully clear to me it
sounds to me kind of like understanding
the neural network data structure like
how we have these binary trees then we
understand that they're going to get
unbalanced so we use these red black
trees or something like that is the same
idea if we have these neural network
data structure and we know that it's
going to become sparse like as a
consequence of how it does it so we kind
of know to inject just like guide it
towards the sparsity that kind of is a
natural prop like property of the data
structure
but I yeah like the idea of doing the
initialization is interesting it Rosie
of like hyper networks like maybe
there's some meta learning way of
entangling the initialization with a
known structure that yeah you know yeah
there's yeah some really nice work
bye-bye loop nets from I think from
Google brain who looks into you like
this idea of learning and kind of
optimizer strategies so meta learning
these things are like a bunch of
different tasks and and coming up with a
schedule or a metal urn schedule for how
to evaluate different type of parameter
configurations for an optimization
procedure for example and I think
there's yeah also a lot of potential for
you for doing something like that with
lottery ticket initializations or
initialization is more broadly and yeah
but that's something I could never do
with my compute budget right so yeah I
feel that so so if if we pull this prior
experience to the extreme I think if if
lottery tickets end up being something
like a prior then it's more likely that
we're going to find some kind of
constructive proof to generate lottery
tickets right it's like oh okay
it's it's like an inductive prior
because this and this and this and this
and then we're able to say ah look I can
just create a lottery ticket I can just
construct one from first principles
however if it's more of an experience
thing it might turn out that just you
know it just happens that for this task
or these two tasks or these 20 tasks
this thing works right it just so
happens that these numbers you know
they're for these tasks are good and
there might be nothing more to it I
guess the world would be in more awesome
place if the first one was the case but
I'm not sure and Yannick do you have an
idea how you would go from from like
this empirical observation of lottery
tickets to use such an inductive proof
or would it be just something that kind
of pops out and then people are like huh
yeah that's interesting that looks like
a lottery ticket I have no idea but I
think the I think sort of the the
disinfo idea is it gets you on there
like because because they basically say
okay what you actually need is kind of
this signal flowing right in in a
particular way
and the more we figure out about this
them the closer we come to - you know
constructively generate a lottery ticket
is the same with sort of researching to
let's say depth of networks and batch
norm and whatnot and people seeing like
oh or you know the first people looking
at our and ends being like oh there's
this exploding gradient it's actually
really important that we don't have that
so we can constructively generate an RNN
that doesn't have that the first if if
this were today right this might be the
same thing it there might have been
another researcher instead of the
instead of ishmael huber and hoang
writer that that looked at our own ends
be like if i take this sub network of
the RNN it just performs really well
right and never considering the idea
that it's just because whatever other
things don't you know have exploding
gradients so it there might be you know
some some properly that we're not seeing
yet that just allows us to build really
small sparse networks that perform just
as well as the big ones i don't know if
you know it's still open yeah okay so
just just to kind of slowly draw this
thing to a close Robert in his article
finished off with open research
questions and there's three bullet
points here so the first one is you know
what are efficient initialization
schemes that evoke lottery tickets he
talks about could meta learning
algorithms give us good at
initialization schemes is it possible to
formalize optimization algorithms that
exploit these tickets can connectivity
and weight initially ization be
disentangled and can the tickets be
regarded as inductive biases so that
that was the first thing let's just take
a quick pause on that do you guys want
to comment on that i think we just kind
of discuss many of these aspects right
so okay so the next one is that a
network has been initialized with
weights that were pre trained on only
half of the training data and then a
final network trained on the full data
set always yields a generalization gap
so in other words pre training on a
subset of the data generalizes worse
than training from a random
initialization so could lottery tickets
overcome this warm starting problem yeah
so I recently read that paper
from from people from Princeton and I
think it's a really fascinating
empirical observation and they do a
bunch of things to try to get rid of
this generalization gap right so they
look at different optimization schemes
different regularization schemes and
yeah I was just wondering if if this is
finding my ally Marcos with the
generalization actually really holds
then it might make sense to use lottery
tickets as one way to probe whether or
not one kid can get rid of these
generalization gaps but yeah I'm not
sure if there's enough scientific meet
there to get right in the sense that
it's yeah just another thing to check in
this generalization gap idea but yeah
there was something that kind of cleared
my mind
okay fans us say that the last bullet
point we spoke about as well so you're
talking about to what extent to these
lottery tickets generalize and differ
between domains so language and vision
and so on and it would be fascinating if
there was some kind of generalization
but between these domains but that seems
to be an open question at the moment
yeah that sound I got to see like the
one people we didn't discuss is is
another paper by Facebook way I arrived
the one where they find tickets in
language and in reinforcement learning
and to me like yeah the paper is a nice
starting point in terms of in some
what's empirical existence proof right
but it really doesn't go in to depth on
all of them right they show that you can
proven or that embedding dangers are
pruned a lot more when when finding
these tickets or that for some games the
degree of over parameterization is
bigger than for others and like Atari
but really investigating what the
difference is in characteristics between
tickets are between these different
tasks and fuels and domains is something
I'm also kind of interested in I would
like to see how they contrast it's
really fascinating well we're about to
draw out but Robert this has been one of
my favorite episodes of streetable this
has been absolutely amazing and before
we let you go I want to ask you a couple
of standard questions which is if you
could give your younger self some advice
what would it be and what do you think
of the state of deep learning at the
moment
huh so I guess this advice question is
like it's a - so I think I'm pretty
happy with where I'm I am at right now
but I think one one thing also Jonathan
I think said was that would have liked
you to take more formal mathematics
classes so I feel a my my passion for
economics in some sense was very much
justified at the point in time and it
has led to where I am right now but I
could sprinkle in like some some
analysis classes that would really
really greatly help me right now
probably and having a different
perspective on things so that's one
thing and the second question was what
do you think about the state of deep
learning at the moment it's quite an
intended question why are you worried or
are you excited so right now that I
think on Twitter there is this debate
about yeah being too competitive and and
too tough rights and yeah I can say like
as a PhD student I can feel the pressure
in terms of getting publications and
yeah kind of showing yourself on social
media and so on but I feel like that
also lends itself to where it's
interdisciplinary collaborations with
for example the people who work with the
fish and have more of a mythology
perspective on intelligence and and
really kind of trying to come up with
new ideas it's it's I guess form of
evolutionary pressure which is gonna
lead hopefully to two nice different and
out-of-the-box research Robert thank you
so much for joining us today this is
thanks for having me thanks for inviting
we hope to have your baracy thank you
thanks Robert thank you very much